it's the ministry of presence sometimes  that's all you need to offer a person  who's in a situation like that is like  just to be present  and she was present for me at a time  when I didn't deserve to have nobody in  my life  it's the first time I really understood  love because I have nothing to give and  I was sitting there thinking like  well I don't have nothing  it's not sexy to be with me don't you  get it like people out here accusing me  of like putting makeup on my genitals  and like shooting dogs and [ __ ]  that's what I'm being accused of and  you're showing up for me like you're  you're gonna be tied to this [ __ ] and  love is irrational that way  you can't rationalize real love